Bienvenidos a la presentación de problemas
de aplicación sobre edades.
Aquí ya tenemos uno.
En 4 años Ali tendrá 3 veces la edad que
tiene actualmente ,
¿Qué edad tiene Ali actualmente?
Hagamos "x"...
"x"...
está muy grande esa "x" para lo que quiero
pero bueno, no importa.
Sea "x" la edad... disculpa mi escritura...
la edad actual de Ali.
Así es que está es la edad de Ali el día de hoy.
Y aquí dice, en 4 años,
¿cuál va a ser la edad de Ali en 4 años?
Pues en 4 años tendremos que "x" más 4 esto
va a ser igual a la edad...
la edad de Ali en 4 años...
¿Qué más información nos dan aquí?
Bueno, nos dicen que en 4 años, esto que
tenemos aquí, "x" más 4...
en 4 años... en 4 años Ali tendrá 3 veces la edad que tiene actualmente...
la edad que tiene actualmente es "x", nos dice que en 4 años cuando su edad es "x" más 4,
si es que esto de aquí en 4 años lo podemos traducir como "x" más 4, ¿qué pasa?
esto va a ser 3 veces la edad que tiene actualmente...
3 veces la edad que tiene actualmente...
Esto es "3x", resolvamos esta ecuación, vamos
a restar a "x" a ambos lados, nos queda "2x"
es igual a 4, de donde "x" es igual a 2, así
es que Ali tiene actualmente 2 años de edad.
Podemos checar que esto cuadra con los datos,
si actualmente tiene 2 años,
en 4 años va a tener 6 años que es
3 veces su edad actual.
Así es que está correcto.
Hagamos otro problema.
Bien, borremos esto y voy a intentar teclear
el nuevo problema.
mmm... ¿qué está pasando?
Bien, el problema es...
Nico es 4 años mayor que Ulises.
Hace 2 años Nico tenía 5 veces la edad de Ulises.
¿Qué edad tiene Nico actualmente?
¡Ah! este es un problema más interesante que el
anterior y por supuesto más complicado,
pero si vamos a poder resolverlo.
De nueva cuenta ¿qué queremos encontrar?
Queremos encontrar la edad de Nico actualmente.
Entonces hagamos lo siguiente, supongamos
que aquí vamos a poner a Nico
y acá abajo vamos a poner a Ulises...
Ulises...
Y luego por aquí vamos a poner hoy, la edad
que tienen actualmente y aquí 4 años antes...
No, no, no es 4 años antes es 2 años antes,
me quedé en el problema anterior, la edad
hace 2 años...
2 años antes...
Muy bien, esta tabla va a ser de gran ayuda
para resolver este problema,
está un poco chueca mi tabla...
No importa, nos va a funcionar bastante bien.
Así que si queremos encontrar cual es la
edad de Nico actualmente, vamos a asignar
para la edad de Nico el día de hoy "x".
Nos dicen que Nico es 4 años mayor que Ulises,
así es que esta información, déjame subrayarla,
esta información que nos dan aquí, mencionando
que Nico es 4 años mayor que Ulises,
eso nos permite establecer que si hoy la edad de Nico es "x", la edad de Ulises hoy es "x" menos 4.
Y esto hace sentido pues nos dicen que Nico
es 4 años mayor que Ulises.
Ahora, vayamos al pasado.
Esto... esto va a ser, así.
Entonces, 2 años antes, si Nico tiene "x"
años hoy, 2 años antes ¿qué edad tendría?
Tendría "x" menos 2 y hace sentido, supongamos
que Nico tiene, digamos 10 años ahora,
hace 2 años tendría 10 menos 2 = 8 años.
¿Qué pasa con Ulises?
Ulises hoy tiene "x" menos 4 años, hace 2
años tendría "x" menos 4
menos 2 y esto es igual a "x" menos 6 y hace sentido.
Nota que aquí también se ve esa diferencia de 4 años.
Ahora, si te fijas, el problema aun contiene
información que no hemos usado.
Hace 2 años Nico tenía 5 veces la edad de Ulises.
Así es que estamos, en este caso, aquí estamos
describiendo la situación 2 años antes
Nico tenía 5 veces la edad de Ulises...
Nico, cuya edad era "x" menos 2 tenía 5 veces
la edad de Ulises cuya edad era "x" menos 6.
Escribamos eso matemáticamente.
Nico hace 2 años tenía "x" menos 2 años,
es lo que estamos viendo aquí y esto era
igual a 5 veces, 5 veces la edad de Ulises,
que hace 2 años era "x" menos 6.
Y ahora, simplemente resolvemos para "x".
Tenemos que "x" menos 2 es igual a "5x" menos
30, ahora resto "x" a ambos lados,
así que ahora tenemos, "4x", he intercambiado lados, espero que esto no te confunda,
menos 30 esto es igual a -2,
de donde "4x" es igual a 28
y finalmente "x" es igual a 7,
hemos resuelto el problema.
Actualmente Nico tiene 7 años de edad,
veamos si es esto correcto.
Actualmente Nico tiene 7 años, Ulises tiene
7 menos 4 que son 3 años, hay una diferencia
en sus edades de 4 años, Nico hace 2 años
tenía 5 años y Ulises tenía 1 año,
al hacer "x" igual a 7, obtenemos 7 menos 6, 1 año.
Así es que está correcto, Nico es 4 años
mayor que Ulises, Nico tiene 7 años, Ulises
tiene 3, hace 2 años Nico tenía 5 veces
la edad de Ulises, hace 2 años Nico tenía
5 años y Ulises tenía 1, así es que todo funciona.
Impresionante, ¿verdad?
En fin, ya hice un par de problemas relacionados
con las edades, voy a hacer más,
así es que siempre vas a poder regresar a este sitio de videos para ver más videos de este tipo
y resolver dudas que te pudieran surgir.
Espero que la pases muy bien.